because there's a limit to your strength
but God Only Knows to some degree what
that limit is you know people can be
unbelievably tough unbelievably tough
and I think it's even the more admirable
for human beings to be tough because
we're so conscious of how we can be hurt
and we're so conscious of what that hurt
can lead to you know you can have your
family taken away from you and you can
be destroyed and the fact that you can
be courageous in the face of that at all
is something that is absolutely
unbelievable right and people deserve a
lot more credit I think then people give
themselves because the fact that we can
be honorable under conditions of life
and death right of suffering that's
that's a testament to the human spirit
and there's a profound anti human ethos
I think that pervades our culture you
know that considers human beings cancers
on the planet something like that you
know and that there should be less of us
it's the same spirit that motivated the
guy who wrote the book about it better
to have never been it's like I don't see
it that way you know I mean I think
people do pretty well for you know for
having their leg caught in a bear trap
and their head caught in a vise they're
actually doing pretty well because life
is really hard and the fact that we're
not absolutely brutal and murderous all
the time is really something remarkable
given what we actually have to contend
with that we can go out of our way to be
honest and generous and altruistic and
to care for each other under
unbelievably dire circumstances and to
act nobly sometimes under the most
trying conditions you know in
Solzhenitsyn's Gulag Archipelago he
tells story after story of people who
acted abysmally but also people who
under the worst threats imaginable never
sacrificed their character you know in
reading about that is really well it
really makes you wonder that's that's
what it does